when I saw why you're crying I saw my
life and I was like damn and you took me
out of in the living room my parents I
saw somebody going through what I
complained about what I didn't like and
you made it funny the mangere bit Yeah
the tasting the same man that had me
dying I didn't I didn't think we I had
met somebody who lived the life I live
so when you came up or when that came
out it changed everything everything to
be like oh you know what
I gotta be true to myself
hello everyone foreign
[Music]
you know I I would like to say that I
I'm gonna say that
um
I was in a place maybe
30 years ago where I felt very kind of
you know it's like boxing you know I
looked at comedy from the beginning as
bio I love boxing and
a lot of boxers have never [ __ ] liked
each other some some dude like like
Ollie and and Frazier
and Ali would you know clown them and
all that stuff they really had a lot of
hate for each other you know uh Larry
Holmes and Ali because he was you know
kicked his ass and stuff and in a
business where it's a singular business
like comedy
and
when dudes come up no no but there was
no social media so nobody
really kind of opened their arms to
anyone it was just a very you know hey
that guy's killing like they they talk
more about you when you're not around
than than when you were around but it's
hard to forge any lasting friendships
because that's right it's like a war
it's like the war with war go out and
one dude wraps it up and it's a wrap and
you never see him again never see him
again
[Music]
you know I had this dude uh that used to
be kind of like one of those comedians
that went into tux you know and he'd be
out there and he had the pinky ring and
he goes yeah you know I was a Mater D
and he tried some jokes but all right
not not funny but he's trying comedy
right yeah and I went to go see
I think Fast Times at Ridgemont High and
my friend Ernie walked the guy down and
he was in his tux
and I said hey what you doing man you
got a show and he [ __ ] took his
flashlight out and he went no I work
here
man he worked in the theater yeah we're
in the same tux wow they used to wear on
stage
and you're just like wow man it's like a
survival of the fittest and you know
even if you're fit it doesn't mean you
make it but to get to a place where you
can welcome uh Latino comedians into
your show and help guys and not have
anything in your heart that's bad for
them or towards them I think I think
they're all great and you know what man
that wasn't me [ __ ] 40 30 years ago I
was like [ __ ] those [ __ ] yeah
no I could see that and that you almost
have to right now because you have to
have a and because it's like when
somebody would say
didn't you help I said I I I I had an
opportunity that I created you helped
them because of that like without the
George Lopez show
it gave somebody a template you know it
gave somebody an opportunity but every
week that you're over there and every
week you're a [ __ ] comedian
man your [ __ ] kidney could go out
your [ __ ] leg you could fall you
could hurt yourself you could [ __ ]
break your [ __ ] elbow it's a [ __ ]
hard [ __ ] business yeah but you have
to be funny in that [ __ ] time man no
matter what goes on in your life so to
be able to you know just to see Jesse
here man and have them on the show man
it's [ __ ] is is great man I only got
one question
[Laughter]
thank you thank you
what are the chances of somebody getting
the kidney that's [ __ ] up and being a
comedian what are the chances
yeah but welcome man welcome no thank
you thank you everything you're saying
is so true like even when I first
started I had that little thing of like
man why isn't George or is it but then
learning and being in the game yeah I
get it no I understand why you were
closed because of everything you went
through because I go through it I'm
going through it too and I'm just like
hey no wonder he said [ __ ] everybody
looking when I walk everybody's talking
[ __ ] and we were like cool and then at
first everybody's cool and then
everybody starts talking [ __ ] about just
like hey so so we weren't cool so that's
how you really feel and then you're
gonna be like damn the better you get
the everybody was in media is it lambia
you know what I mean but that's like you
know but Latinos were so used to it
because even with their families you
know and the dudes that are [ __ ] my
mom's like hey let's go to the club
together yeah
yeah yeah the nice ones is the worst
ones you want to be around with like oh
you're wack okay they were [ __ ]
they're out there in a few more hey
everybody
I feel more Comedy Club there has to be
a level of for your [ __ ] police
officer man if you're if you're like hey
don't I have a partner in the car
[ __ ] this isn't a [ __ ] LAPD
oh this is law enforcement this is a
sheriff we write alone what yeah oh I
don't [ __ ] do hey at some point man
like I always say at some point
if you're a boxer you got eight people
with you 10 people they feed you they
cook for you and the only time they
can't [ __ ] help you is when you at
some point you gotta [ __ ] fight for
your own yeah that's right and when you
go in that room and that door closes and
it's ten guys and you say to yourself
why not me why can't why can't it be me
not looking at them going all those
things are [ __ ] better than that [ __ ]
those fools yeah that's right let me in
there let me in there why not me
everybody's asking why the [ __ ]
Latinos why hey go move your car why the
[ __ ] I tell you to move your [ __ ]
cars that [ __ ] one go pull your
[ __ ] car while we're talking that
you're not gonna tell me move your car
that's right so yeah I was I was jaded
like that too in the beginning because I
went to the Laugh Factory the comedy
story and I saw the politicking and the
kissing ass and that wasn't me I was
like I didn't grow up like that so it
was hard for me to work there yeah so I
just say you know what [ __ ] I took a
step back and I went to those little
Mexican rooms you know little [ __ ]
bar gigs a little private gear I learned
how to grind it out on my own it says
you know like the the real real version
of myself not like this what remembering
to what they want remember Rocky and Mr
T Mr T was in their [ __ ] smile like
culo in there
in the little room that's what that's
that's how you get better you get better
when you go to a place where nobody's
really seen you like a gym it's all it's
kind of like the gym and you go to the
gym and when you can go to those places
and and do stand-up and and not ever be
like right now dude like you're next
they both what [ __ ] that's the thing
that's what he's saying is so true
because people don't know that that's
what makes a real comic and you can tell
who a real comic is because when you go
through all that all that freaking those
kids and you gotta fight through the
[ __ ] Dodger game on and you got to
get their attention and you gotta like
fight through a guy fighting right now
like all of that builds you as a strong
comment because then when you go to The
Comedy Store and you do go to the Laugh
Factory these other Comics are sweating
you're next that's right because you you
putting the [ __ ] fear on them because
you're like yo I'm bringing jokes like
real jokes not this my minds are like
one-liners and yeah a little clever
comedy what the [ __ ] I want to make you
laugh you can't hear the [ __ ] laugh
about your real [ __ ] and and when you
when you look at something and you have
to say
um when I was doing do shows
you're like can can anybody do this show
ask yourself can anybody tell these tell
these jokes can anybody do if if it
wasn't me could somebody do this exactly
yeah yeah and when they say yeah it
doesn't have to be you but when it has
to be you then you're on the right Road
that's right then you play you paid your
dues then you're in a place
let me see your name
you know and then you just now you're
just you know you're
and then you [ __ ] look you you know
you you throw this out and then you got
you got one coming in your head that
your nose is great and you do that and
then you throw yours and they think you
made it up on the spot and they go
[ __ ] crazy yeah then you're you're
nice It's a Grind It's a Grind It's a
Grind it's like it takes it takes a a
strong person to go through that
especially after years of the years
you're like what am I doing everybody
over here back home is like getting jobs
and getting houses and it just it hurts
because they're like everybody everybody
living their lives and [ __ ] they're
still looking at me you're still telling
them my mind really even my family
they're like
uh call that guy come over here
yeah my uncle always [ __ ] hey they
know construction that makes it man in
your way
do a comedy man let me do this it takes
a long while to stay focused and and
you know uh
it depends on like the if you what what
eye you have you know uh uh
um a detective or a police officer you
don't touch the area you stay back when
I bought my house and in Toluca Lake
uh I was working all the time so the
guys that were coming to work yeah were
didn't see me they only saw a hand light
skin Oh yes and I came out one day with
a thing under my arm with jeans and a
thing and the guys the the little
Mexican dude that was working there with
a fence he says hey
inside
[Laughter]
and uh I told Ann that I was [ __ ]
Laughing Man I mean I loved it and
Anne's like which one was it I said no
no [ __ ] that I love it I love it I love
it yeah you understand it it was an
honest sure it was a yeah it was a real
thing those are the real those are the
real things man like like
our family members like if it's your you
know it's your dad it's your uncle it's
your uh partner it's some you know uh
man it was a [ __ ] little Juanita dude
man we should play this Sunday baseball
league
like a [ __ ] bad like a like a buy
some Bad News Bears [ __ ] all
dark you know but he'd be like this and
they go and and you start hearing uh in
the league talking about them they go
that [ __ ] everybody go that [ __ ] dude
you know guess what it's bad in average
is Jordan I go about
300.300 [ __ ] 750.
he's been up a hundred times he has 88
hits [ __ ] you nobody has 88 hits it goes
and you can't strike them out that's
funny and you're like [ __ ] that's
funny and then we play for the
championship and then you're looking
around yeah yeah and you go which one is
portfolio and you look and you your eyes
go like this and then it goes down and
you're like that's him [ __ ] Mexican
dude dark skin like almost red little
red [ __ ] you know he's running you
know oh you're like [ __ ] yourself
High School I [ __ ] played against
some dudes from the college and I'm
pitching that [ __ ] goes up here
like this and [ __ ] my first pitch
[ __ ] double [ __ ] whales
[ __ ] get this all [ __ ] up
the family
that [ __ ] caramela [ __ ]
and you're just like [ __ ] it so you
gotta hit off your first pitch uh humble
too like is it good
that was amazing he saw shotgun it's
okay it's okay
like that but first my friend [ __ ]
comes up again [ __ ] running a second
and third [ __ ] start with a curveball
that [ __ ] [ __ ] another one the
[ __ ] double [ __ ] is that [ __ ] this
dude that's true and uh yeah judge a
book by its cover for sure we're used to
that how come he's not on the Dodge
negative yeah [ __ ] he he they won they
won they won no I mean did you hit him
did you pitched through a little curve
I'm trying to strike that [ __ ]
you couldn't strike him out you're about
to match that you can't light you still
[ __ ] hitted it dude
well you were a pitcher or what yeah I
wait you're like you're like just
[ __ ] thingy construct that
[ __ ] out that's funny that's
hilarious
he's 411 [ __ ] you gotta be a
Dodger foreign
you can't make it up like you can't tell
right like you know you're telling a
story and they laugh people laugh laugh
laugh and you can't make it a lot of
[ __ ] my [ __ ] comedians are
like oh you know my girlfriend man she
didn't like you know when I smoke in bed
I said I told the dude I didn't know
that you had a girlfriend no I I don't I
thought I just made it up
that's true if you're making it up then
[ __ ] her every night they're [ __ ]
talking about [ __ ] sleeping and
swither
those are the things man like you know
you hear a story you'll know if it's
coming from a real place or he's trying
to cater to the audience you're like now
this is coming from a real [ __ ] place
and you know the sooner you can see like
you know [ __ ] magic
but you know it's like it's like you
know a [ __ ] magician he's like you
can see the trick I wouldn't [ __ ] do
it then it takes his [ __ ] thumb off
it's rubber right here he puts that
scarf in there yeah yeah it is that
makes it disappear that [ __ ] thumbs
the five size is bigger there's you know
like yeah yeah if you the thing about
being a comedian is you can't see how
the magic is like you have to see the
magician not do the not [ __ ] do the
videos you can't see the joke coming you
guys got to surprise you yeah right yeah
I see what you're watching you you have
that there's that's all you got to watch
it yeah
dude there's no yeah I watched you for
years so for you to watch me it's like
damn that's good you know I don't know
what that you know
yeah clearly you know yeah and you see
guys that that saw you and in the wake
of them man there they are man yeah and
you know that's not [ __ ] easy for
them not easy for me it wasn't easy for
me at all yeah and it's not easy for
anybody I don't give a [ __ ] what color
you are it's not easy no but these dudes
man keep going and they keep coming up
and they keep going and they're all
different yeah like Willie barcetta like
I never sat with Willie you know yeah he
gets down and what I and what I didn't
know about him is that
he's more like a he would have been a
[ __ ] great Professor man like
Professor yeah he's like the one-liner
King right he just like comes in and
just he's sharp yeah but when I when I
first started it was like trying to find
my voice that's the thing about lately
you're struggling the first couple five
years trying to figure out who you are I
was trying to be this white comic yeah
and it just wrecking record little
hoodie of course
the little dance with the Vans the type
bands and the hoodies like the little
string and come on right on there yeah I
had a I had a dirt don't need me nothing
in it
I saw you white boys [ __ ] looking at
him and I was like oh yeah me too I
gotta go over my nose
and then they just see them what I go
back to like prior and you and and I
just like the stories because the thing
about when I saw you and um and that's
because I'm on here better like when I
saw why you're crying I saw my life and
I was like damn and you took me out of
in the living room my parents I saw
somebody going through what I complained
about what I didn't like and you made it
funny the mangere bit Yeah the tasting
the same man that had me dying I didn't
I didn't think we I had met somebody who
lived the life I live right so when you
came up when that came out it changed
everything everything to be like oh you
know what
I got to be true to myself so what you
did was you open doors for people like
me to say my life yeah because you made
a universal and that to me was like man
I'm always going to be grateful to your
special because I'm happy man that that
why are you crying change everything for
me I was like my whole like blueprint of
what I thought comedy was it's like nah
it's not trying to cater being true to
who you are and tell your own true
stories because no one could take that
away
like yours yours no one can take that
and you know when they and when they
tell you that they don't get it because
you're not they're not Latinos it's
[ __ ] yeah because when nobody knew
me and I was talking about not going to
the doctor or drinking seven up or
taking the ice from inside the freezer
and making a [ __ ] snow cone out of
whatever you know root beer or uh you
know the the ice tastes like fish or all
the thing you know you see that [ __ ]
right there he lived that like that you
can't make that up or like my
grandmother said if you if you didn't
drink a Pepsi she would put a new uh
[ __ ] towel in there and she goes
you're not drinking another one until
you finish that one it [ __ ] tastes
like black olive juice all the
carbonation was gone
you guys still have one in the
refrigerator
to keep the carbonation like this is
some [ __ ] [ __ ] don't let them
open it and um it's all those things
that when somebody can you know paint
the picture for you and then you know
you you start to be able to to uh to see
the things that even if they are even if
they hurt yeah
that's when you know they're on the on
your when they [ __ ] when they hurt
when they you know when they hurt you
and you can still make uh people laugh
yeah I think I think uh I don't know if
it's Latino but when we talk about like
we have stories about like spanking
stories that makes us laugh man like if
you're ape like the other day they grab
me everybody hit my brother and it's
like it was a [ __ ] up situation but
[ __ ] is it funny you start dying yeah
dude he grabbed my mom grab them and he
found he kicked them again like they're
dying white people oh my God that's
strong
is he okay no no he's not that's the
funniest guy he still walks on Twitter
like we love that [ __ ]
we live next door to a guy and he goes
he goes we gotta get out of here man I
go how come he goes I [ __ ] do drinks
next door and then he comes out and uh
the the sun is chasing the dad with a
belt
I'm right across the back it's like this
he's like Jared
[ __ ]
but you know those are the things that
if it was like anybody like you think
about dudes like uh uh you know where
they would be talking about the [ __ ]
airplanes eventually yeah oh yeah yeah
like the stirrers came in like one Niner
like four I'm like and I'm gonna be a
laugh Factor like just like how and why
bored and I'm just like maybe it's not
my style but I like truth I like real
plays I like comedy KKK I could I could
I live that so I understand that you
know but that that's just not for me and
when you gotta when you got your own
Rhythm yeah you can make you can make
your own
you know what what does [ __ ]
Mayweather fights like sideways one of
the only dudes that fight sideways see
and you see like that works you know
um I saw that's I mean I mean I knew
everybody yeah I know it's crazy and
seeing everybody and you know I saw
George Carlin in the Pasadena Playhouse
just amazing man that's great looking
amazing man yeah but you're around the
greatest like yeah the fact that I was
here on the other film podcast you were
friends with Richard Like Richard Pryor
like the fact that you even got to like
meet him was it's just amazing to me man
dude that must have been like
[ __ ] Richard Pryor thank you Richard
have you seen this I've seen this [ __ ]
now I show my brother and he's still
dying Long Beach one is amazing that's
the they're just we just we sat there
watching an infomercial last night the
wife and myself
for 100 bucks all of Richard Pryor's
history you know if you want it on yeah
whatever it's it's on DVD well a lot of
people don't even have DVD players
anymore
what kind of shot imagine that [ __ ] now
for a limited Time
Magazine the best of George gobble yeah
about these these classes were gone
forever no they're not you know Richard
every one of them every one of the ones
that do show the old stuff new stuff it
was it was killed what's your favorite
uh Richard uh bit you know what I think
a joke but you know what that's what
it's coming out about Richard Pryor
which is which is which is true is that
the [ __ ] had like debilitating
stage fright
debilitating stage fighting wow and it's
just coming out like we had the the same
manager and whenever he was going to do
any show but he did show in San
Francisco I think uh is something I said
or one of those and in the afternoon he
would say [ __ ] I can't do the
show it's three o'clock Richard
you got to do the show [ __ ] I'm
telling you I can't I can't do it
[ __ ]
God we'll do it tomorrow it's like no no
no no so now you got to stay from three
till nine with him
so that you get them to do the show
because he doesn't want to
he's scared that's nervous and he's like
stays fright and then one thing where he
starts I hope I'm fine he does that he
says this guy's like yeah [ __ ]
and somebody heckled him and he clicked
on and then he became Richard Pryor but
in the beginning of that album he says I
hope I'm funny and he said yeah
[ __ ] you better be better be
funny and and he he needed an adversary
moment like like the thing about Michael
Jordan that that guy said Hey Man Nice
Nice game Mike and and he then he
scorched the dude but it was it was made
up in his head like he needed it to oh
you need that little spark to just go in
yeah you go in the zone yeah would you
get nervous
I used to get nervous yeah I get nervous
[ __ ] man I still get nervous like but
when I'm on I'm on like when I'm on
stage and I grab the mic it's like it's
like a fight once you get hit like all
right I know the strength I know the
feeling all right cool pero I I do get
I'm not gonna I do get nervous I miss my
head how was your let's say how did how
did the children yeah
I swear Hey listen I dream IBS isn't
funny
you have IBS my [ __ ] well you got my
job
and it happened to me in an Ontario
Improv the wings don't get
how does it affect you does it matter to
the show or it has to be a Big Show or
you know what it's every show every show
because like I don't know what it is but
I go in it I'm in it I'm not giving you
like a half-assed routine I'm giving you
my moment I'm in me as a child me as
like a kid yeah yeah so I get lost and
I'm in it and I have to connect with you
the audience yeah and if I'm not
connecting that's the fear it's like are
we connected today like I don't know I
just
I want to give you everything but that's
like being an actor that's like being an
actor too like you know comedians that
they would say and I I think it's true
that that comedian is can't act but
they're doing an act but it in an actor
you know comedians are doing you know
we're doing this hey then the dude came
here
over here so but then when you're acting
and you do you do a sticker you do a
part or you do you even go do an
audition and you have to be like this
but if they go yeah and then Jim came
right and says hey Jim get more fast and
they're like no no no no no you got to
be yeah you're you're you're mine is not
you it's the character and yeah without
knowing it
you're the you know how there's two
sprinklers one that sprays straight and
then you turn the little button and then
it goes and it goes back you have to be
both yeah you have to be this on stage
and then when you audition you have to
be another [ __ ] person that's true
you have to be another person that's
true that's the one I saw though why are
you crying you said at the uh you said I
didn't look at any notes this is how I'm
just ready and I was like you see that's
because you're in it and you can tell
when you see it you're [ __ ] in it and
I'm like oh this was like not even here
with us he's in this [ __ ] world it's
true and you're and we're we're seeing
your childhood and it's like full like
yeah that to me was crazy to watch yeah
it's true yeah yeah and um I watched
them all dude and Sandra Bullock was
there like we were we had already done
the show and she was and I said can I
bring you out and she's like come bring
me out don't bring me out and I wanted
to but I'm glad I didn't because you
know she was like no I don't believe
this is about you and also
you have to be able to
see you have to be able to see it you
know if you're you have to have
instincts of good instincts of of
whatever of this of the thing but as a
comedian man
you can't just think about yourself as a
comedian you have to be able to think I
want to do this and I want to do that
and I want to do a special and I want to
do a special in
Texas and I want to do a special in my
hometown I want to do a special there
anything that's out of the the norm of
your comfort like I did my specials
[ __ ] live
dude
[ __ ] I remember that [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah
live San Antonio so it's like um tall
dark and Chicano that's right and the
name and the name so the name a kid that
goes to went to Irvine College had a
Chicano study class in Irvine first of
all I told the dude first of all what
you gotta studies You're Gonna Learn
[Laughter]
and and the guy said to me the
government I remember the college kids
said that his professor said that
Chicano was a derogatory [ __ ] term oh
and I said [ __ ] him that [ __ ]
that's [ __ ] chicano's like somebody
that was born here that's here you know
I said this is how it is when you come
from Mexico and you get here and you're
drinking beer you take your shirt off
and when you're born here you keep your
shirt on yeah I saw a Latinos are like a
basketball player the shirts and the
Skins the Skins are from Mexico and the
shirts I never took my [ __ ] yeah
the hairy pants rolled up
gloves
the tire they [ __ ] blew out they've
made sandals so that's [ __ ] true
that's these [ __ ] fighters in Mexico
that's not a real sandwich
I said I told the guy I told the kid I
said hey man I'm gonna do a uh a special
and I'm gonna and I'm not maybe I didn't
try to put Chicano in the thing or
somewhere right and then
they said uh tall dark and handsome yeah
and I was like
tall dark and I said man tall dark and
Chicano [ __ ] title man ass [ __ ] it's
a great the [ __ ] title man [ __ ]
[ __ ] came to me man somebody said
tall darken and and handsome you know
you know what I mean like what I loved
about you when you were [ __ ] when you
did America's Mexican he said [ __ ] that
bull the [ __ ] that [ __ ] that bootle
[ __ ]
my dad was like
essay
because he were the voice for us and
then we were out from Arizona I'm from
Tucson so we all wanted to say that to
him
and you said in front of oh that [ __ ]
was so hard that was like and that's the
first time I said FTP oh that's special
so you know you hyped everybody up
George Bush
my dad was like gay werewolves Arnold
Schwarzenegger [ __ ] that [ __ ] the Erica
because they're all because like you
know immigrant parents are timid they're
surprised you didn't want Erica Trump
didn't say double [ __ ] up double
[ __ ] up with them surprised you know
that Mexicans always you know if you
give him a 20 they give you a change for
a 10 you're like hey you gave him a 20.
they [ __ ] still ten dollars
I come here all the time and I work in
the construction with my uncle they
shorted him a little bit he's like nah
if I can't now I'm gonna tell him he's
like no no no no no no no no no no
they're gonna fire me
you deserve you're an extra 20.
yeah and I'm over here telling him he's
apologizing for me and sorry this guy
hit the knot
the guy's like now dude here's your toy
so so uh yeah so
yeah HP would always come and see me
like the week before that they would
approve this stuff so I said [ __ ] that
blue though yeah so then Tuesday
I call HBO and talk to the lady Nancy
yeah
and they said well I had Aaron uh you
know uh and all the people from that's
it
I said listen um
I don't think I should uh
I don't think I should say [ __ ] that
puto to the president
I just think it's a little too much I
mean it's right in the beginning yeah
and I just think it's it's a weird set
of a tone I don't know yeah and then the
[ __ ] Nancy said to me would Richard
Pryor
Richard Pryor
That would have hype me out of like [ __ ]
that football Richard Pryor call and say
I don't want to do that damn and I said
I I got you thank you you see that would
have hyped me up too double [ __ ] up
you know I'm gonna do a special call
[ __ ] that Bulldog now right but isn't it
found man like yes it's [ __ ] it
nerve-wracking man yeah but isn't it
[ __ ] fun oh it's the best [ __ ]
feeling and you know what it is it's all
that thing I went through as a kid not
getting the attention I needed and it's
like that center of attention is what I
was looking for and I just feel like
out here I'm trying to figure it out but
up there it's like I got it I found what
it is that's feeling that yeah but
outside I'm still trying to be a better
me but up there it's like I don't know
it's like I just feel like I have
control but you know what and and
and
and as far as t as far as shows go like
I saw
um Drew Carey uh Liberty I saw Drew
Carey in his car living in his car that
guy and I saw him do The Tonight Show
you got [ __ ] Johnny Carson called him
over he was a [ __ ] star the next day
the next [ __ ] day Bruce Alford I saw
Tim Allen in Indianapolis before Home
Improvement and he had a Showtime
special called like more powerful who
did that [ __ ] and from [ __ ] A to Z
from A to Z the [ __ ] show was there
yeah you just start to see these guys
and they had the show were in them like
they were created a show yeah and I
didn't I didn't I was just sitting
inside the back and said man I don't
I don't have that I don't have my only
child and then I went to Caroline's in
the early 90s and Dave Becky was one of
Chris Rock's managers of three Arts
Michael rotenberg now my manager 30
years later and Dave Becky came to see
me Dave Becky was the manager of the
Improv in San Diego and he came to see
me just because he was in town he was a
big manager Chris Rock's manager he says
Hey afterwards equals hey man can I give
you some constructive criticism I said
yeah
he goes when I see you man I don't know
what you like I don't know where your
politics are I don't know if you have a
family I don't know if you're married I
don't know there's got to be somebody in
your family that was funny like what is
it like I see you it's just kind of a
lot of the same stuff yeah and I was
like
wow man like wow and I remember thinking
he's supposed to kind of being somebody
in your family that's funny man like
it's like yeah you know I was like yeah
yeah yeah and then I walked back to the
and I said my grandmother yeah yeah yeah
and when I started when I started doing
that it was over man yeah that tough
person it was over
we'll definitely bring out the funnel my
dad was that it wasn't that strong but
like my dad was that where I was trying
to get a [ __ ] compliment way you know
my compliment I would tell him I want to
be an astronaut an astronaut you just be
the biggest Aston
that's being in the bathroom
he's like I could never be that I don't
have one I gotta be in the spelling
spelling be I have it spell this it's a
big ass [ __ ] word I didn't practice
that word
let's see you're like dude but if
they're not [ __ ] hard on you man it's
like what would have been we would have
been once there's no [ __ ] choice
either yeah there's no choice yeah that
that that this is due to Abraham his dad
was a [ __ ] nacho he comes over there
fighting the station he go you want to
go to McDonald's
that [ __ ]
and then they would get cold the [ __ ]
the the [ __ ] the lard on top look
like a [ __ ] skinny room a Rockefeller
Center
in Greece right now
and then I'd go in there my
grandmother's been [ __ ] that much
[ __ ] Grease Grease and she would turn
the fire on it
I just know what that look like
everybody [ __ ] died y'all how old was
your grandfather when he died uh 29.
hey those are the best beans though
I started talking about the [ __ ]
bacon grease and the Folgers can with
the bacon grease in there and on the on
the on the stove they would have a you
know they would have a not chock full of
nuts because that was a high profile
yeah you know not like the Cubans a cafe
buster
for the special we went to New York and
I took my mom and dad and my dad's not
used to being anywhere you know but we
went to an Italian restaurant used to be
there anywhere yeah you should see that
guy [ __ ] I'll tell you the stories went
to the Italian restaurant a nice one I
see it's like I'm a pay I'm a [ __ ]
and he wanted a coffee he's like they
brought him an expression and grab the
guy before you don't touch the waiters
okay I want coffee come on I don't want
this goddamn coffee you have Folgers you
have and the guy's like oh we have a
latte
yelling at me
don't ever bring me here again
thank you so much I paid and he's like
for that no the whole day dude he was
talking about look at that 99 Cents
pizza that's all I want I said yeah
show you something nice yeah he's like
huh the whole day he's talking about
like well you could have done with that
150 seconds we could have done this for
150 if at all
where was that in New York in New York
in the Chelsea uh Hall the Chelsea Hall
yeah that was uh it was scary because
like I got there on Sunday we were
filming on Thursday and they wanted me
to do some like spots yeah I've never
been to New York and I brought my Dua
check this one out I brought my family I
brought my girlfriend my mom my dad I
flew him out they're with me we land
they got the camera crew we're gonna hit
up a spot they're following me around
I'm nervous I'm like hey chill with the
camera now we're gonna show you yeah the
grind and yeah and I'm going to the
first comedy club New York Comics
there's like hey what's up what's going
on what's all this and it's like oh he's
doing a special for who HBO a word I I
go see what's up all right and then they
say my name it's just your next
everybody in the Green Room goes to
watch me well I'm sweat I'm [ __ ] nerd
they got the guy in the front with the
camera yeah I go up dude my dad is
watching my girl everybody HBO's there
all right bombed so hard because the
pressure I couldn't I couldn't the small
stage I tried to do my act up I'm
[ __ ] talking fast and then dude I
knew I [ __ ] up when the camera grew
the camera guy was like we brought the
dog
and I was like embarrassed and then my
dad my dad getting in my head too he's
like hey Seth are you sure you're gonna
Ching out
are you sure because they bought the
hotel they're gonna make us pay come on
to dinner they're gonna
[ __ ] dude and uh it took me two days
to kind of snap out of it like I'm in my
head it's because of the New York and
the whole and I thought I saw Dave
Attell and I was in my I gotta be like
them and not myself well I'm myself so
you know what I think it's probably a
good thing that that happened
because uh you'd rather have it happen
there than to go and kill and be like oh
man I got it and then take it for
granted like no that's what it's never
done I always have that in my head too
I'm always like when it's too good I'm
like something bad it's around the
corner I don't know if that's uh yeah I
don't know but I've always like uh
that's like something bad is going to
happen I always have that like and it's
just good to be true and it's a [ __ ]
like
it's never easy but
when it's going your way man it's like
it's like gambling dude when it's going
your way everything goes your way like
it's all it's all good and then you can
hit a [ __ ] stretch of [ __ ] where
you're just like man [ __ ] this man like
yeah like but you know when I like being
an only child and then my grand my
grandparents not giving a [ __ ] about
about me and you know and wanting to
perform you know and then they were
going door to door with a [ __ ]
accordion to give accordion lessons
and I said I said I said Grandma I want
to play the clock
uh 10 lessons yeah for like uh thirty
dollars oh [ __ ] and
I went to two of the ten
and the rest of my life I had to listen
about the [ __ ] accordion a 30 year
old man Grandma I'm gonna do Arsenio are
you sure
you're gonna play the [ __ ] accordion
oh that's right you're gonna take the
[ __ ] man
[ __ ] accordion
and then and then uh
what'd she say when you told her you
wanted to be a comedian George oh
yeah what did she say I'm funny
it's my dad right there too um
the night of the pilot you know that
wasn't an actor you know to take a
little bit longer it took a long time
and you know with Bruce you know Sandra
is everybody there
took from like [ __ ] forever because I
want to make sure you got the moments
you know let the audience go Grandma's
there [ __ ] driving home by 2 30 in
the morning my grandma's just looking
straight ahead and I'm driving her I'm
getting close to the off ramp right
there on the five Freeway San Francisco
I said what I said what'd you think
Grandma
and without even looking you want to
know
and I and I said yeah and she never
looked at me she's looking straight and
she goes if I would have known it was
going to take that long I want to stay
home
and I looked at her and she never looked
at me
and I said yeah wow man wow and I and I
said wow and and uh I told the L.A I
told the New York Times that and then uh
and then the New York Times did a
calendar thing on me on the front page
of the calendar in the New York Times
and it said a life so sad it had to be
funny and I thought wow man it was at
that [ __ ] bad like and then I got in
Time Magazine
and the guy wrote George Lopez talks
about his grandmother he should thank
her because that's the Muse to his
entertainment is his grandmother and and
I said um
um what do you think of the character on
the show Grandma you know excuse me she
says you made me nice [ __ ] said you
made it yeah
it's a woman that was like when a
relative was like that I was at first I
was very like judge you with my dad but
then I realized how he grew up and I'm
like I was a little bit more
understanding of why he became can you
imagine man like like what was your what
did your dad do when he was [ __ ] like
a young girl he was [ __ ] working at
[ __ ] he'll tell me every day he's
like
I already had a job I could have had a
wife I could have had kids the best they
want to be a [ __ ] Community
he tells me now he's like I should have
been a comedian
every year when I wasn't like getting
anything done I wasn't getting paid when
I first started if I was I'm gonna go to
show you his passive way dude you know
what he did to me you know what he did
to me he [ __ ] took me to Paramount
Pictures to he says I'm gonna take it
somewhere around pictures because he
thought that I didn't have the balls to
go tell him he thought it was like that
I just had to go and tell him hey come
over here
and we walked in there and it was a
writer strike it was during the writer
strike yeah it was like the I don't know
but it was like 75 or something like
that but dude uh and the [ __ ] writers
were [ __ ] marching the white burritos
one you know yeah yeah yeah they're
[ __ ] insurance they're not getting
rights and my dad's like hey he tap one
yeah he's ready he's ready he's like for
a while he's ready come here he's funny
he's ready he wants to oh my ready and
I'm like that is not a word it's a
process
you need to go tell him [ __ ] yeah dude
I'm like it's not that easy he literally
took me to permanent pictures for
outside [ __ ] man it was [ __ ] I
couldn't believe it the people were
laughing they knew what my dad was
trying to do so they were like it's fine
here's our car just we'll get you to act
that picture the parallel pictures
he did tell me one thing that made sense
and I did do was uh I became uh at the
Hollywood improv I became a dishwasher
to get in you know oh wow yeah dude I
came in as a dishwasher oh [ __ ] I didn't
know that yeah yeah I walked in I was I
was working with wow he was the manager
and uh you know I was very timid because
everybody wanted stage time and I saw
how Rita was very nice but you know what
the best how they [ __ ] did it man
like that's how they did it like back in
New York the [ __ ] were like uh you
know yeah my daddy said hey don't I
think about my dad dude like he's tough
and all but he was he made it he made it
here in America like he knows how to
work the system he's like be in there be
in if you're the help [ __ ] it you're the
help but then show there's gonna be an
opportunity and oh lo and behold dude
the opportunity came they needed a comic
and I said I can go up and they threw me
up five minutes and after that it kept
throwing me up every now and then find a
[ __ ] dishwasher like my pants were
wet dude I'm doing the [ __ ] jokes
that's the first time I saw Trevor Noah
and he gave me props he was like hey
good [ __ ] yeah but uh but yeah I mean it
was uh you know how it is the [ __ ]
grind you know I didn't like to talk we
don't Latinos we don't talk yeah so we
keep it timing we're just ready for the
opportunity when it comes you better
just bring it you know and that's what
it's been through all my career it's
been like just waiting for the door to
crack in for me to just [ __ ] run in
there when I can and what do you and
what do you want to do man like are you
acting or you want you want to have a
show I want to yes yes I want the show I
want the [ __ ] I want my life I want
the because I think you have older
you're dead right you're having your dad
your mom and dad still married yeah
they're still married they're together
my mom's not quite I you know with my
dad she complains to me about my dad I
know when I stick up for her he's like I
didn't say that no noches
that it's like I'm like my mom did and
then brings my mom and Mom no but you
know I think you should look at you
should look at your clear I mean of
course I mean kind of [ __ ] advice
but you look at your life and see how it
applies to a TV show well right now I'm
working with with uh I'm looking for
like writers instead of helping me like
create this because you know I'm very
I'm trying to write but it's like I'll
go all over the place
I need the structure it's gonna you know
like I'm looking for someone who's put
in the time that I do with stand up yeah
for them with the writing because let's
be honest you know the the uh uh it's
crazy man I mean uh when I used to watch
Drew Carey uh and I was in the 90s I was
early 90s I was living in Sherman Oaks
you know and and doing the clubs and
stuff and at the end they would say
created by Drew basic drug uh Drew Carey
and brew and Bruce Halford and I would
tell and where's my Bruce Alford right
where's the guy that's gonna help me
and you know who it is
the first one in Bruce Alfred I saw him
today we did the run through the with
the show with the daughter yeah [ __ ]
Bruce Alford Man by the way I auditioned
for that no I didn't get it I wasn't
bison enough but I I didn't get oh you
get something else
we're a moving company
they were they were good yeah
but I know what you're saying like I've
always thought about that too but again
I was just like just be ready my thing
is like just be ready just be undeniable
kill it every time I go on that stage
like let them know why and my dad every
time I hang up the phone with him he's
always like hey
let them know why why are you such why
you missed birthdays why you miss like
you know upper being with the family
every time I go back home I see my dad's
hair getting greater and greater it's
like that [ __ ] does to me something to
me that when I go on stage it's like I'm
not like these guys I'm gonna try this
out no I gotta kill yep I didn't come
here to try I came here to like I gotta
execute this is what you this is what
you need and this is what
this is what I found in it and it worked
the first show they would say because
you know they always say well how would
you describe the show George and I would
be like how would I describe so I said
um I want to prove to my wife I'm a man
and I want to prove to my mom I'm not a
boy yeah that's it yeah that's the show
and that was it dude that was it and it
made it was fast
you know I try to prove to my wife and
two I never had a I never had a father
that I could be a father to my kids
and a husband to my uh wife and and my
mom wouldn't think I was a [ __ ] boy
and it was and everything revolved
around around that [ __ ] small
description that's true that's [ __ ]
of like of that you know and when you
find it and you can tell somebody like
that they go oh oh yeah that's
interesting the Llorona lady drawing her
kids at night she cries
well that's beautiful they get excited
when I hear pain oh that's awesome
that's [ __ ] beautiful ain't the
better because the less they have to
think the [ __ ] better the better it is
yeah no [ __ ] when I when I went in there
with Bruce and Robert the other guy we
would tell stories you know and I would
tell them about my grandmother and I
would tell about my grandfather and
[ __ ] this and you know
[ __ ] it they [ __ ] the [ __ ] dresses
don't tell her don't tell her everybody
dress stuck in the back of the [ __ ]
thong I like the face he did too you're
like hey
um and when we started to write all
those things down Bruce had already done
[ __ ] Drew Carey done Roseanne
and they didn't want they didn't make
first time
actors or comedians creators of a show
because because you're giving away
[ __ ] millions of dollars yeah so they
would say if it was Bruce and Robert
then Warner Brothers makes more money
so when we started to get the pilot tour
I had to fire my mom and we had to work
together the airplane Place Factory oh
that was a gun yeah uh Bruce came to me
and he said hey man they don't want to
make you a creator of the show but and I
didn't even know what it meant and he
goes but I'm going to go over there and
I'm going to tell them that without you
there's no show it's not me it's you
like we're listening to your stories
like we're writing them down but I can't
and that's what he said he told Peter
rob the president I can't write these
stories that's right like George is
writing the show George has to be a
creator
you know because without him we don't
have a show yeah what's the show that's
and that's how they [ __ ] can't say no
to you that's right let me do a show and
I'll [ __ ] sell ice cream in the
[ __ ] [ __ ] that [ __ ] [ __ ] you
gotta have where your dad is like you
open at a restaurant and he's like hey I
can't for this like you gotta start
somewhere right that's true man that's
why you guys so hard every episode you
still see to this day it's like it's so
honest and real that it was undeniable
let me tell you something yeah but I
mean I think I may have I told the story
I got a DUI pretend to Mrs Lopez thing
that's why the story
the good ones bear repeating no no but
it's [ __ ] that people would say to me I
put I put in the [ __ ] I put in the show
yeah that things that real people said
right I put in the show [ __ ] I had Rudy
Moreno [ __ ] in the show hey you know
[Applause]
I'm hitting little party
his bird [ __ ] mittens
if you fall in Fire and you can't create
a [ __ ] show out of falling in fire
with a little [ __ ] I used to call him
up guys what I used to call boots or
mittens I was supposed to go he's been
after me to go tonight
he's doing a [ __ ] fundraiser every
week
what's up it's like the [ __ ] water
game you've been funneling the money
back bucket back door channels that's
funny
a little kid that has a spot on his
lungs yeah Rudy's like lift your shirt I
gotta put some marker right here it's so
funny Once I paid for the first one for
I felt like I was responsible hey don't
just don't start drinking dog I already
paid that hey like I invested in [ __ ]
don't be smoking or drinking though put
money in I'm not doing another one
another beer yeah
you want me to go I know but at what
point did Rudy become the the [ __ ] uh
Jerry Lewis a fundraiser fundraiser yes
where's all that money going I don't
know
what you're saying at the beginning
you're like okay yeah and they started
to use pictures of viejas or a [ __ ]
heat please [ __ ] coming up and you're
like and it shows up in your email
you're like hey what the [ __ ] the [ __ ]
is this is
a model model will not be at the uh at
the event but yeah like putting shrimp
on a [ __ ] hook he wanted me to go to
the show tonight I was supposed to leave
for San Diego tonight oh no way but I
was but I was too uh the day has drawn
on have been a busy day and then this
series this came on Thursday the show so
now I've decided I'm too [ __ ] tired
I'll go to the [ __ ] deal later
the [ __ ] porch Golden Pond over there
yeah with the podcast
[ __ ] yeah
kills the times like I'll come tomorrow
if you need me to come you're like hey
well [ __ ] yeah
this week I've had calls from Texas A M
and ASU there you go to go back there
and uh do some stuff from but the most
exciting thing I'm doing is the guy that
was gonna bring in here the guy that
called me up and said I heard your name
on on the radio George Lopez says yeah
so I called in his son has a limousine
company serviced down in Temecula yeah
but he Services San Diego and everything
talking about doing a
take me out on a little wine tour but
careful for another one
you know you can spend the night here
and we can just talk about things that's
how they
started
you'll be bleeding for your [ __ ] kill
your physique is I'm 72 years old that
[ __ ] doesn't hit me now
exactly you're gonna be facing it out
wait where am I at eh you're in a nice
place your wine country now it's doing a
wine tour yeah with Gill in the bus with
people what and talk about
stalker
and to make it just for the for the fun
of it I'm going to use them because I
got five couples who's gonna go on a
wine tour but for him to go out get some
people up there and just talk about it
Latino National Treasure that's [ __ ]
documentary when I saw that he was me I
was like that's what's up I was [ __ ]
honestly proud that I'm like that's
what's up dude like he the way he
explained is live everything we all
related
with the little PSA I thought like a
little [ __ ] like he's trying to be a
lady
my wife asked me if I was if I had
helium in me that day yeah you were like
maybe like you wanted to be uh
I know in the beginning
[Music]
[Laughter]
I'm still [ __ ]
[Laughter]
when I saw this dog I was like get the
[ __ ] out of here yeah I thought it was
the only one I was gonna rep it I'm like
I don't know make another [ __ ] Gary
Stanley Gary was a trip man I knew Gary
a lot I met Gary in 1979. that's crazy
and he drove up he wrote I think he was
riding on Sanford and Son or shows and
he had a 280Z that's in 280Z and he'd
pull in and park right there on Westwood
Boulevard of the common storm West where
the internet would be over there and he
had the [ __ ] purple windbreaker and
he put it on it was all [ __ ] wrinkled
from that yeah he had that shoulder bag
with like as a writer and he would say
uh how does how does my hair look George
and I said looks great you can't even
say say swear to God I would say sorry
you know what's funny about those
[ __ ] Comics I trip out when I see
their documentaries and like how they
didn't they just got the job they're
like I rode and I don't know what I was
doing I'm like what the [ __ ] I've been
trying my hardest out here and I don't
get [ __ ] dog like these fools are like
uh like uh a bunch of dogs all those hey
so in 2005 I hadn't seen gear I hadn't
seen them in Forever 2005 we're all
hosting the Emmys mid corn O'Brien uh
Ray Romano Brad Garrett Gary shanling uh
all a bunch of guys Wanda Sykes
everybody that was like uh yeah
I'll kill it
hibiscus dude
[Laughter]
ah
I threw an IPA in the freezer though no
it's not good so Gary's challenge you
know I see a man and he's like hey you
know after so many years ago [ __ ]
standing backstage and he goes so how
are you handling it man having your own
show and you're [ __ ] this and all
that I said it's great he looked at me
and he goes [ __ ]
tearing me apart you're scaring
everybody man he's like [ __ ]
[ __ ] let me tell you man like
that I wrote I wrote those the jokes
there for the for my I gave away the
first Emmy to uh reality show oh really
and I wrote all this [ __ ] like uh
Extreme Makeover in an hour you're
you're beautiful as it doesn't is that
what a trump pack does
all that [ __ ] man I love it yeah and
um and was like you know [ __ ] hands
like oh my you're not gonna tell these
jokes sorry yeah dude and I said you
know what
give me the papers back go go over there
that's why you don't let anybody see
your [ __ ] man day before I'm working on
them upstairs yeah and I think I thought
so I'm sitting there all The Sopranos
Will and Grace everybody [ __ ] every
all right Brothers Raymond they're all
there um and they come and get me
and she gets up and I said no no I'm
going you stay here what
I'm going backstage no no I said to her
you burned your backstage pass yesterday
do you want somebody with you
get out of here and and I'm [ __ ] on
the side of the stage and they're going
to the commercial it's live yeah and I
go to the commercial
and I [ __ ] lean around the corner and
I see
Gandolfini and [ __ ] Will and Grace
and in the middle of it and the first
row is Robin Williams
looks at me and he goes like this
oh there you go
so it is and I said [ __ ] him you don't
need anybody else
right there that [ __ ] comedian not an
actor that was it man yes comedian that
was it and I [ __ ] nailed it man he
was so happy man like I did Scarface
smell those Jews that were in there
killed that [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah I love
that one oh okay
the timing was like oh man and I went up
and and you know what man like Al Pacino
said you know they call me they go Al
Pacino wants you to do Scarface for us
AFI I said no what I said [ __ ] don't
remember Rocky where he gonna say rocky
how would you like to fight for the
world championship of the world
and he goes no no I thought I was going
to be a sparring part like he said no
wow in a movie why'd you say no he was
afraid
no you why'd you say no because I was
afraid you were free yeah [ __ ] yeah man
because I I didn't have a little bit of
fear to have that I was gonna just go
out there and he goes Al wants you to do
Scarface stuff for us I said no no
[ __ ] no I'm not gonna do it and he goes
we want me to tell him no
that's it I said call me back in half an
hour
upstairs and I was just like what do you
I said hahaha
and I said the only way to do it is to
do it as Tony Montana yeah so [ __ ]
and again like I'm in the day of I go
down I guess I'm flowering I put it in
the bag she goes what are you doing I go
at the end I'm gonna put my face in the
powder I'm gonna look up and I'm gonna
have fit that's cheap that's a cheap
laughs
you know I love the laugh good joke
makes me laugh yeah I worked on the
movie heat without oh and so were you in
the movie no I made the cutting big boy
I made The Cutting Room floor I made The
Cutting Room floor I was a technical
advisor
I made The Cutting Room floor I was
Consulting advising on the movie did you
have a part in it or not no he was
saying what's real and what's not right
let's give the people at home because
yeah
hello hello give an example of what a
consultant does yeah it advises they
they watch me do interviews with other
actors I was supposed to be the cop so I
could learn what a a real detective
would be like you know hey cops wouldn't
do this cops wouldn't do that that's
what I'm doing on the set well they
wanted to see how cops interacted so we
went out to a place in Santa Monica nice
restaurant you remember which one it was
no no I just know they had a private
room in the back we're back there eating
yeah
they wanted to see how we inter
interacted oh actors and and and how
cops talk to each other and what they do
ah I got you and so we're telling jokes
and I remember Michael T told a joke
[ __ ] awesome you know it was a great
[ __ ] joke and then Al Pacino wanted
to get involved and he told a joke and
the chick I'm sorry no you know but the
guy that I was with from homicide he
laughed he laughed his ass
so we got the comment we got in the car
on the way home I said hey did you get
that [ __ ] joke because I didn't think
it was funny he says neither did I said
your ass he says that was a courtesy
[ __ ] it so the next day we're out there
we're talking
and I S and Al's gonna give it another
try say hey before you do let me tell
you that joke you tried last night it
didn't [ __ ] go here sometimes the
courtesy you told him yeah
like a hot girl at a [ __ ] club how
old was a great cow was hugging me he's
a great guy
now we're just [ __ ] he wants to see
what cops like today that was that was
the truth Michael T
he says when they're on the set for uh
uh
Forrest Gump he says we're filming it
out in Georgia he says we break for the
night we're done he says I can see one
of the extras out there is having
trouble with his car he says and and
everybody's leaving and I felt bad I
left him on the side got out I said hey
you need to write you haven't remembered
your car the guy said yeah he said would
you give me right in time he said sure
come on get let's go he says so the guy
starts for my car he says oh wait wait I
forgot something he went and he goes and
gets a bag that was inside his car comes
and gets inside my car we're driving
down the road and he says as we're
driving down the road I noticed that the
guy keep looking inside that bag and
then close it back up
and just for conversation I finally said
hey you must have something really
important in that bag what do you got in
the bag and he says None of Your
Business [ __ ] so Michael says I
slammed on my [ __ ] brakes he says get
the [ __ ] out and as soon as he stepped
out of the car before he could do
anything I [ __ ] punched it and I left
I kept the bag he says and I never saw
that [ __ ] again
and I said really I said what was in the
bag he said none of your business
[ __ ]
yeah
Hook Line and singer pull me in it none
of your business [ __ ] same thing
the guy allegedly had told him yeah wow
that's [ __ ] great oh it was funniest
[ __ ] joke they were the dude out
there the Ron Pearson that does the
warm-ups I make him do this joke he goes
like guys passing by a mental hospital
and he hears 13
13. and there's a little hole in the
wall he looks in there the [ __ ]
Pokemon
[Laughter]
[Applause]
that's a great warm-up that's a great
warm-up guy you have yes
you know what like like guys like us
that talk about family yeah we can't do
[ __ ] audience warm-up we can no I
can't I only have one yeah talk about
[ __ ] we're going down the street for
a [ __ ] hour
it's a certain skill for certain people
bro like that [ __ ] is not for me it's
the [ __ ] hardest thing to do so when
I do corporate gigs they're like well
you gotta like I got this like you want
this or not no I'm not gonna cater to
your [ __ ] company hey [ __ ] this is
what I got it's true it's stuck out
wrong way you know that guy is a [ __ ]
amazing he's amazing wow amazing
somebody said to me the one of the the
executives said you know I had a friend
there he was very rude to her I said
listen this [ __ ] is the best guy
that's out there and you want the best I
said if you want me to talk to him and
tell him to go easy on people I will but
it's not it's not in my nature as a
comedian I would never tell another guy
guy to go eat like now he knows where he
is and if it becomes too much then
we'll deal with that but you hire a guy
to do something let him do it
they made that person sense of whatever
but
when you walk out there and you don't
know if you're gonna do five minutes or
55 minutes [ __ ] that yeah this guy was
amazing you couldn't have asked for a
better match so good I've seen him I
think the Bible words
hey and he's got the fastest hat for
that [ __ ] slap hat the guy was he was
[ __ ] again he does a thing man where
he [ __ ] uh puts a hands on top of
that slap game slap your hands oh he
does that move yeah and he's good he's
good I got laid on the girl was like
let's play this game
[Laughter]
do you have any issues in the
relationship that are like well we're so
different yeah what did you mean though
no no I mean from your childhood that
came up
it's very like oh my God like I tell you
I'm like this dying and her mom were
like oh my God that is terrible and I'm
like no I don't know yeah this is my dad
and then yeah there is a little like and
look what she said about the jokes I
tell her a joke it's like raunchy and
she's just like that's not I wouldn't do
that if I were you I wouldn't go but
then I go on stage and they kill I'm
lazy you don't know you don't know my my
voice you don't know my [ __ ] but she is
helpful with certain [ __ ] like she
doesn't know how to organize stuff yeah
and she's like can I have the industry
but she's like she works for the Dodgers
she does like the inside host and [ __ ]
oh man she's a great lady
she's good cool though like she could
take a joke like real quick and she also
like works
yeah she's the whole inside the host the
inside stadium what's her name uh
Jessica Rosales yeah I don't know if you
know her yeah but even the name
[Laughter]
I'm surprised you didn't ask the big
question
Jesus even my kids my son
breakfast with my wife my son yeah and
myself and he says Dad don't look down
but if Jordan heard said she's got big
tits
and even my wife who I officially call
Sister mayor Clarence because she's
she's the religious good one ah right
even she knows that George is going to
say does she have big tits oh I got that
then all right I don't understand that
that's what I do the guy Matt Williams
who's like button that he he did uh yeah
for uh for Tim out straight guy and I
would we were working on uh St George
and FX and you know we great writer you
know and I would say this she had big
titties and he would be like what's that
yes so so we were in Santa Clarita
working on the show we're writing the
things up on the board and the girl
comes in goes the acting coach is here
she has a one o'clock meeting and then
Matt goes does she have big titties
[Laughter]
uh the nuns are here do they have a good
thing
[Laughter]
when I work together
makes them look bigger yeah in
construction there was a spice in North
Carolina there was a spice that dude
that were always like and it was just
like [ __ ] he had a [ __ ] the guy that
owned the company had a [ __ ] assistant
she was [ __ ] you can tell she said she
was like you know yeah I'd like for a
girl to be a [ __ ] because yeah I can
tell it's almost like I would get it all
day come here and I would grab it so I
told the prices the prices were like Hey
how do you say
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
I got a phone call the other day at my
house you know the department saying hey
there's this guy
so I called a guy up and I said uh hello
is Leroy there and he said yeah there's
Leroy who's this I said this girl Korea
listen I got called by the department
they said you wanted to talk to me and
you were a longtime old friend and I
said he said yeah I said I apologize you
know Leroy I don't remember you oh wow
and he says give it give her listen to
this hey come and see yama mama
and I started laughing he was the he was
the black elevator operator
slick smooth
talking [ __ ] all the time on the
weekends at the Hall of Justice we used
to have jail visits up there so ladies
would come in there and he said and one
day he says Hey Gilbert watch this young
good-looking Mexican money goes up there
he says uh can I help you ma'am and she
looks at him and she says no I'm Looking
Glass he turns back and looks at me says
yo hablo español
[Laughter]
in my apartment when I was growing up
and he was just all my cousin hey my man
hey he's your cousin that's a bad [ __ ]
right there yeah
and I remembered Leroy and we went and
had lunch together yesterday you did oh
wow yeah he joined us you guys are cool
oh yeah he was cool he's a good man
what's he doing did he retire oh yeah
he's old he's retired now still looks
good still looks the same
[ __ ] looks thin too bothered if
anybody looks thin when they're retired
it bothered me but he looks dead he's
good and it was a he was a funny funny
man and worked uh
every moment was it didn't matter he was
an elevator operator you know he was one
of us Lee Trevino uh you know and I were
like we're like family so she went to
the golfer oh he says that he had he had
his big caddy Herman so Herman African
American your big do three times bigger
than than Lee and Lee and Herman were
like Batman and Robin [ __ ] beautiful
relationship and uh uh he goes he goes
man he goes to Herman man he got
diabetes man he couldn't walk around the
course sorry I retired him I said are
you here man you can't make it man you
don't make it around you know I'll tell
you what I'll get you a car I'll get
your apartment and I'll give you money
so you can live you know and he goes
that [ __ ] lived 25 more years
I was at his house
and Herman was and he called him up man
I got a chance to talk to him then they
were just like just so you know Augusta
at the Masters it's like all you know
very white and then they're walking up
the ninth hole and and Lee Trevino goes
to Herman amen when we get up there man
give me a hot dog man hot dog
so he goes we're on the tenth hole and
and all the people are around like this
and I see Herman and all the people and
he's holding the hot dog out and it's
got the foil on it it's open and he goes
bring it out here and he's like this no
why not he goes bring it out of here man
walks out there and he's holding the the
hot dog so it's a big African-American
guy in at Augusta Georgia holding a hot
dog out for a Mexican golfer and Lee
Trevino goes did you tell him it was for
me or did you tell us for you
[Laughter]
when was that when was that in the
[ __ ] in the late 60s man well I was
that that's right that's why I
volunteered to go back to Vietnam in
1969. they sent me to Georgia and there
were still segregation back there how
about that he said did you tell me it
was for me or did you tell if it was wow
[ __ ] and he and he goes man I didn't
need a hot dog but I just did it
together come out and [ __ ] hold it so
so literally again 71 he wins the
British Open and the guy that he's
playing Tony Jacklin and this is this is
the power of the [ __ ] Chicano man so
Lee Trevino is already Master's Champion
I ever talked about Tiger Woods but
Trevino was doing it was doing it when
there were no Mexican's birthday so
he's playing at Muirfield and Tony
Jacqueline is a European golfer and our
European golfer hadn't won the British
Open in forever and they're playing
together and Lee Trevino says man I'm on
this par five man and I'm struggling man
you gotta get it out there and that
[ __ ] Tony Jacqueline says to him hey
Lee
finish up in a way like hurry up hurry
up you finish so then I could I could
hit okay and he got in the sand trap and
he's like this [ __ ] and he and
it went in on the from the soundtrack
and he chipped in six times over the
weekend
and they played on Sunday and it was
close and he was going to win and all
the people coming to the middle of the
Fairway and Lee Trevino walked past him
and then he turned around now they're
walking towards him but he's walking
backward he goes hey man a Mexican's
gonna win your tournament
in Europe a Mexican's going to win wow
and they all wanted that and they all
wanted that dude to win I mean it
clearly I mean you can see Tony Jackson
yeah and [ __ ] Lee Trevino showing
over there let's see nobody chipped in
[ __ ] chips
I'm [ __ ] it's hard hardly you're
[ __ ] childhood oh hell yeah dude
that's what I love you you get a good
round you think I could do [ __ ]
everything
yeah you did during the pandemic every
matter of fact I still haven't I told
you I had a set of golf clubs that I put
up in the yard sale and you said no no
you just bring them out bring them out
let's go all right
my girl's dad I've always wanted to did
your dad ever want to play golf nah [ __ ]
no my dad never wanted to go he's a
soccer I was soccer that's why I like
God watch this
yeah yeah
That's Tony Jackson right there yeah you
know hey look at that watch this
nice and easy
what's this look at that
yeah
if it didn't go in that thing was going
100 feet by look at that yeah you see
how fast it was when it when it hit yeah
before it was going to get another
there's some other ones there's some
other ones too
that thing man one hop boom boom boom
that pole [ __ ] saved his life what
else there's another one like over the
weekend there's a couple over here look
at that fool look at the I love this
dude man
look at that look at this look at that
look at this
no no no way that's the worst isn't it
where you get it right there and then I
think that's it because that's a win is
that to win I don't think so there's
still more time for the audience at home
we're watching uh some golf clips from
the 1972. uh British Open uh yes look at
that 17th hole that food does look like
I think that's and where they go to the
oh are they tired
look at this here we go here we go watch
this here we go watch this oh my God
poodle [ __ ] that don't match brown and
[ __ ] blue no for me I would chuck
that [ __ ] right there watch this
watch this
I'm almost 11.
look at him
he's running look at him
look at him oh [ __ ] candy that
[ __ ] dude look at him man what do you
think he used a seven and like a putt or
what look at that
man listen okay I'll tell you what yeah
yeah the the the time that we the times
that we kick in into a [ __ ] gear that
nobody has is when [ __ ] don't
expect you to be as good as somebody
else would be normally for sure you know
what I mean when you said hey it's the
same guy and they're like [ __ ] that I
always bring it up that there's the same
guy don't [ __ ] that it's multiplied and
then they talk and you knew they were
talking [ __ ] about you yeah yeah I had a
guy in my car yesterday that told me he
says you know I gotta I gotta be honest
with you he was an old the guy's 90
years old now 89 years old and I picked
them up
I picked him up to take him to this
homicide luncheon seasonal timer retired
and been retired 35 years now and so uh
he's sitting tell him he says you know I
remember when you were working the case
he said I remember when guys were
laughing behind your back he says you
were saying it was one guy he says and
uh it wasn't you were right he says I
remember them doing that to you [ __ ] man
I'm sorry and you know what man in a
case like that you don't have to [ __ ]
be right once sure yeah I mean how about
that like you only have to be right once
like you [ __ ] said hey this is a this
is not this is one dude yeah and they're
like oh this [ __ ] of course
they're going to underestimate you
because of the color of your skin and
because I was younger and and plus
nobody had hit criminal history had ever
done what I was alleging yeah and still
today nobody's re there has been a
copycat
that's the thing I [ __ ] I don't know
what it is but what did he do man he did
[ __ ] that nobody knows he was a cannibal
right no no cannibalism but he was a
pedophile
he was munching like a [ __ ] for
some reason the vaginas were chewed up
he didn't he didn't there were no
cannibalism he there was pedophiles
girls and boys yeah he was raping and
sexual assault on on women he was
killing men uh the weapons he used were
everything from Guns knives machetes
blunt force trauma manual strangulation
look at your strangulation so it's just
different what is that in somebody that
does that it's it's it's uh what is
their thing that it's like they're just
awesome in my opinion it's all sexual
yeah something's off like they when they
get off of like the sexualness of
killing somebody stuck out there's a lot
of sexuality that goes into this
mind hunters and then when I saw your
[ __ ] it kind of makes sense when they
talk about the trophies they keep yeah
only went two seasons man they [ __ ]
done they're [ __ ] good man they were
[ __ ] great man always good man but
but but we've been watching your your
guys's dog night not that like just
seeing what you went through and
everything and just like a challenge how
come they haven't come back and ask you
to do another one like another one that
was the best dog man right right it was
shot the greatest admissions initially
it was trending number one for about a
week and a half
and then it was number six in the world
Netflix was extremely happy I've been
told and they wanted to shoot another
they want hey let's do a follow-up and
then they finally came to the decision
well what do you that one was so good
what more could there be
after that right now and then they went
into some other serial killer yeah but
right now uh I have a zoom call uh
tomorrow morning on Netflix
I don't know if I can make the next
episode no no no no George is not my
wife knows number one George is number
one no I like I like the the that dude
looked like he was tough that [ __ ]
night stalker but then when he talked
hey satan I'm like get the [ __ ] out of
here this is not that scary no matter
what he said that that [ __ ] and
everybody's like oh my
at one time he's doing this on the table
we're talking to him he's going like
this oh no I get scared of these people
and and I just look at him and he's
looking at me and he's going like this
and I said go ahead and fill it in he
said Phil went in I said the pentagram I
said that's what you're doing
and he says you know about that [ __ ] I
said yeah he went
erased it all was that he was going to
draw the pentagram pentagram gave him
power which is a symbol of the Satan and
so I just said that [ __ ] doesn't bother
me Rich you do what you got to do that
stuff doesn't work
I watch a lot of [ __ ] ghost stuff
right the ghost stuff in my house here's
the [ __ ] they started doing in Mexico
they're like they go to Mexico hospital
and they go yeah oh yeah
and a [ __ ] thing
see
alcohol
when I first met mama he was like hold
on wait a minute get up get the [ __ ] out
of here
wait a minute tits are hard something
happened in your life thank you I I told
Momo we went to see your show uh when
they were taping the first one first
episode
so I told Mom and I said hey by the way
if you listen to the episode the other
day I said I'm laughing my ass off I'm
almost or George was talking about you
saying hey did you get momo on your set
if you did that's a killer he's good the
show's gonna [ __ ] die don't let him
and I said and this [ __ ] was funny and I
couldn't stop laughing more but I was
not laughing at you Momo I was laughing
at George that's some good stuff okay
you're a big boy dog you're a big I'll
tell you man I want that way I'll tell
you I wish for you that you would that
you would have an opportunity to create
yeah a show that because it's it's the
[ __ ] it's it's I hope so it changed
my life I need to send her uh well maybe
you're my Sandra I don't know maybe I am
maybe I am yeah yeah because it really
it really man it really [ __ ] does
mean so much man like
the this episode that we're doing right
now is a is a every Lopez Lopez versus
Lopez so every episode is Lopez versus
anxiety Lopez versus oh that's great uh
Christmas so in this episode
the for my original cast comes back
how's that and does the show man how's
that how's that feeling and so at the
table read the woman that played my mom
and the guy that played the best Valente
were at the table read I read the script
and at the end world the the first the
the people that are on the show right
now mine and I said somebody knocks the
door I said oh you know my you know the
ex-wife doesn't believe it's a real
Latino Christmas unless there's like you
know 10 people on the party on the door
I said and the line was uh hello family
and I started crying yeah did you really
good that's beautiful I couldn't say it
you couldn't say it no
Turn the Page
and it's right there and you're just
like
[ __ ]
they're all looking at me in a second
wow that's That's Heavy towards you yeah
that's heavy with only two of them there
and I just messed like and I told Bruce
I said hey I'll come and he goes because
things are so different now man it's
like nobody knew you were you you know
we're trying to do something and then
there you are man like and 20 years
later here they come back
and there you are again you know what
was their reaction
they yeah same thing yeah and to me to
me like you do to me you did The
Impossible like you did The Impossible
like when especially now when I going
through what I'm going through I'm like
looking I just think back of you and I'm
just like damn like how I'm like how and
then like seeing how far you've gone
like it's just like damn dude like
you're one of us and you [ __ ] did it
like just as honest and you went for it
and you got it and you know how we hear
stories and I was afraid of me I was
afraid of me too to be honest with you
because I'm like I look up to you so
high and I'm like I don't want to get a
bad moment and be like ah [ __ ] that like
but
it's just like there's no way because I
feel like we grew up the same yeah maybe
not exactly but the same of feeling like
we weren't looked at and we weren't like
and and we also were the same as far as
like we were at these comedy clubs and
we're like you know what all right well
I know how this works [ __ ] it then you
guys want to see me go I'm gonna go hard
that way you won't ever forget about me
that's right and [ __ ] it then that's it
that's what it felt like because it's
like yo you want me to bring people to
this and it's like you're getting these
guys because they're kissing your ass
and it's like that's not me because I I
have something to say and they say all
right all right if that's what it is
okay we're gonna play your game but when
I come back
I'm gonna come back undeniable you you
won't be able to follow me in the comedy
story and [ __ ] sunset in the early
80s I was back there and I wasn't even I
was in the middle of a conversation
there were guys who were better than me
and one guy comes in uh uh I can't
remember who it was and he said together
guys those guys are regulars there and
he says this guy any good and the dude
went like this
and he said you hear any laughter I saw
you [ __ ] just went like this
yeah he walked in stood in the back of
the hallway he was disgae any good and
the dude just went like this
and nobody was laughing and he was like
all right
that's all you need that's all you need
very good
the bent is here
and it's like
you see that's what I'm saying I've I've
had those moments where I'm like when I
come back I want to see like when I see
you you're gonna be [ __ ] walking back
and forth because you're you don't want
to go up just don't go chasing anybody
down the street down the [ __ ] place
yeah but but it's but you know I I think
you know in all of this like and stuff
that there's a there's a there's a
society that we should create for of
Latino comedians yeah well I'll tell you
this I'll tell you this like one thing
that I do
I wish that would have when I went there
to the Laugh Factory there's a lot of
white faces not saying like I'm not
saying it's anything bad but I'm saying
like I saw how they saw themselves like
Jerry Seinfeld will see the writers like
oh that's good let me take you on with
me and I was like it's like man I missed
the big I want a big brother like George
to see me I want Gabriel to see me but
no son I gave [ __ ] it they have their
reasons yeah at first I was angry at SEC
but as like gone through this and saw
how this works and I saw how people are
I'm understanding why you're hesitant
yeah but I'll tell you what we miss you
the comedy [ __ ] we talk about you no
I'm telling you right now we talk about
you like you're you're the goat right
you are the goat the greatest of all
time no one can touch you when it comes
to your material the way you speak your
truth
and we miss you and we just want to see
you bro we just want to see you we have
we have a show called brownish that it's
like one of the top notch Eric Rivera
has a show that he's opening
opportunities for everybody but just to
show your face all these Comics like
that we I hear like yeah all you gotta
do is show things he's good unless he
makes fun of me right right no but for
real you know man it's like we miss you
dude yeah I mean I my life is but I'm
still I mean you see me here you can't
if you make [ __ ] laugh you make
[ __ ] laugh it's like that's
right you know some people they don't
they can't do that they can't translate
the the thing and today we did you know
doing the show with my my daughter but
you were there but also
in the beginning nobody knew me yeah you
know so I so Bruce was like you had to
be a certain way because you were
introducing yourself to people and today
we did the TCA all the report g d wolf
like Jane Wolf is a [ __ ] great
reporter like legendary and she said hey
George Genie like it's welcome back and
she asked me a real question and you're
just like
I'm back man like almost in [ __ ] uh
Color of Money
[ __ ] you know what I mean it's like
it's like but it's you bro the first
time you make it man
you
nobody had ever [ __ ] done it so to go
back and do it again
is like why wouldn't I [ __ ] have guys
on why wouldn't I want to help [ __ ]
guys get their show I should I mean
that's that's what I should do and I do
a free comedy club is one thing but I
should
get a [ __ ] on the air around
this show because you know I even I even
said to Anna Navarro and Navarro hit me
today
she was with Kamala Harris and I and I
said I said my my focus is this show and
getting this show picked up that's my
sock because it's my solitary [ __ ]
thing like the first was to get my
daughter a show the show got picked up
from the pilot
and then now it's to get the the 12 and
then the [ __ ] nine that they want and
even today everything's great but it's
not official until it's it's and you
know what all these dudes would be
wearing them jackets
you know this and it's nothing is is
nothing until it's something that's
right and dudes would always get ahead
of themselves man say oh you know I'm
working on a show over there you know
I'm with Sonia it's like it ain't [ __ ]
man until it's until it is yeah that's
right and whenever I would go to a
[ __ ] audition and they would be
reading in the back they would write the
names of the scripts on the inside of
the like a book right and you would see
[ __ ] a hundred [ __ ] scripts behind
you and none of the shows you [ __ ]
knew what they were and you would look
behind the person you would be like
there's a hundred [ __ ] shows back
there that never got made that's right
like why would mine get made and then
after a while you just have to be like
that's right it's either most likely
it's gonna be no but
when it's yes it's It's [ __ ] amazing
yeah you you and you can't do it alone I
feel like I don't know like you did your
show for your for your own life and your
own thing your own like your own Journey
better like you know every comic when
they do stand up they wish that they can
Inspire somebody and it's like honestly
like you did that for me like you you
made me as a kid I watched you and get
locals I was third grade and I was I
will third grade thinking it's good in
there man you were great you [ __ ] I
was I was [ __ ] no you were you're
still [ __ ] the great but what I'm
trying to say is that like you made me
find you you know what you told me you
taught me how to be true to myself in
this [ __ ] industry in this game but
when you're by yourself I don't have no
guidance right but I say you know what I
would go to a library and I would watch
you
I'll watch all your sets your [ __ ]
interviews and I saw how true you were
to yourself to your own [ __ ] life
your own pain you were Universal and
that was like that's that's that's it
that's what I'm gonna be I'm gonna be
true to me and my voice so I appreciate
it man thank you in the in the in the
white crying DVD there's a half hour uh
of a interview I did in my dresser my
Warner Brothers
and everything I said I was gonna do I
did yeah you did what's the future hold
I said everything I said came true and
it's like Manifest Destiny now that
everybody's trying to be you know
um you can you can what I think let's
call it like you're just put in a
[ __ ] Villa you light a candle for
something but but believe it don't just
light a candle that do something about
it yeah and you know I never did a
candle for somebody who was gone I only
lit a candle for somebody who was alive
because God is gone I've never lit a
candle
you were right I didn't want to cross
the road you go to the Vatican there's a
1000 candles but people like candles for
people that are gone and we need to
[ __ ] light our light for
[ __ ] that are still around
that's right I'm I'm not a comedian I'm
just a lucky [ __ ] in life man
I'm blessed I'm lucky I sat there I told
the other day I was uh in Las Vegas
in my room I had tears rolling down my
cheek my wife says what's wrong sat on
your balls
she says what's wrong you know we're
there and we're there in Vegas for the
weekend to watch that's right I was like
what the [ __ ] that's amazing right yeah
and I just said and I just sat there and
she says what's wrong you know I said I
just can't believe what I've done in
life to be here to deserve what I'm
going through right now man this is this
is all I got him a room
this is all all good all great being
able to go through what I've done uh
enjoying the fruits for now and to be
able to work with somebody that I used
to pay good money to go see that's crazy
and now I get to sit right across from
drinking's beer free you know the first
time I was gonna meet you I uh I was
just too afraid to say hi because it was
Costco and you were
you made a list it was like in Irvine
yeah well I was in Orange County I drove
all the way to because I heard you're
going to be there yeah that's right I
had a text like oh he's gonna be I
[ __ ] drove I saw you and I just
couldn't I couldn't I couldn't say hi to
you then because it wasn't the right
time yeah yeah I was like nah I want to
meet him meet him I don't want to meet
him like forcing I want to meet him
because of what I do what we do yeah so
like the fact that we got this yeah and
what about what about when you came in
like I was was I laying with my feet on
there yeah
he said and he's like hey I wish I could
what'd you say to me I said you need to
learn how to relax brother here too
you're too stressed out to beat her up
like this
and then you and I have never met before
never and then when you came up to me I
stood up and shook your hand that's
right I didn't continue to lay down and
go like this hey what's up I stood up
like a man I shook your hands we ever
met I stood up and it took some action I
appreciate it yeah I hear all these
things
and everybody told me like oh good luck
of luck
honestly I don't think you live the way
he lived because I like I feel like we
lived so I was like I'll be all right
I'll be all right let's get when we go
through the same [ __ ] we just we we know
the the is there people who are veterans
man they're to go to the war you can't
duplicate it you can't explain it to
anybody you have to [ __ ] be there and
especially like this is compared to
living or dying yeah and you see
somebody right you know that man this is
this is all good you try and block out
all the bad stuff you just think about
the good stuff and that's the life
maybe you're a dick
I made myself you know away because I
thought that that that's where I grew up
I thought that that was a way for it was
for me to to work that way was was that
way because it's really it's not it's
not easy to do you know right and and
today when I go uh you know in the
dressing room and I'm in there and you
know uh you know Eddie Van Halen was
like one of my [ __ ] best friends and
to be able to like I I started to buy uh
when he was alive but he gave me a
guitar because we we he was you know I
bought him these [ __ ] pxg clubs
they're like five thousand dollars and
he's like I go to his house and he's
like Ah
that's second because yeah I looked
online they're five grand I said yeah
[ __ ] they're gonna buy you some
[ __ ] cheapest no I didn't get you
anything I didn't [ __ ] buy those
clothes for you to get me anything yeah
yeah and he gave me one of his four
black stealth guitars that's in my get
out of here you have that you have it
and beautiful I didn't I didn't buy them
those clubs because I wanted anything
I loved them and I love them and I said
hey [ __ ] you can play with some
good [ __ ] we he had a locker in Lakeside
that [ __ ] [ __ ] shot still
cleats on the chicken
the [ __ ] his his shoes were so old
they bent up like the wicked Witcher
where can I get some of that stuff I'm
gonna say [ __ ] it right there the
windows are tinted right the [ __ ] Pro
Shop he goes right where I go in there
he goes what I said in there
you didn't know that that I thought
there he goes I thought that's where the
air conditioning was [ __ ] look
at it I told you no I [ __ ] Pro Shop
get out of here that's crazy they're
[ __ ] in there he goes I thought this
is where the air conditioning was
[ __ ] walked in there he was it's
in there and like that [ __ ] is like
[ __ ] that's crazy all your like the
friends that you've made man the [ __ ]
grind well okay I have a question what's
Mo what's one moment that you vividly
remember you're like I I think I made it
my life is Gonna Change like
um
in 2002
I did
um the arm Awards and you teach
I met chich in like 80 in the 80s
in the late 80s and she comes over and
he goes hey man uh amen Carlos
get the [ __ ] out of here
[Music]
and uh was a show out already
the white the the location okay
and uh I went over there and he touched
my face and he told me much he had a
[ __ ] momentum why and I was like what
and
they sent me this picture from his sound
check yesterday we've been friends ever
since that's Carlos with a [ __ ]
beanie on it and I sent him flowers man
every time I worked out I hear Black
Magic Woman every time I work out he
texts me man he texted he texted me at
he texted me at eight o'clock in the
morning
and he said to me I mean look man he
sent me this picture man
and he's like look at us man like
I heard you pulling or something uh he
was look at us you know
the picture
and I said oh yeah I said and I sent him
this one here look at me hey that little
kitty what damn look at you and me and
him man in the morning
you didn't even brush your teeth yet
yeah we all had that drunk guy to be
like no I don't [ __ ] love myself okay
I gotta tape it back up and at 802 in
the morning
um damn fools you guys are closed he
sent me a a a song of him and Placido
Domingo man playing
wow and he said Peace and Harmony love
you adore you cherish you miss you in
damn
now they're going to be performing in
Vegas
every day really does that rock like
everybody that I uh I still have those
I'm driving I'm like I might not make it
back you have those like doubts you're
like what if I'm not lying you're gonna
make I gotta do a fundraiser that's what
I say it's 72 years of age though I say
I don't give a [ __ ] I can't get that
much longer dog anyway yeah you know
I mean but you know how this is all the
people that
I had my posters of the kiss and Van
Halen and Ted Nugent and my grandfather
[ __ ]
and my grandfather would say when you
come home they're going to be all torn
down I said no they're not that [ __ ]
not your [ __ ] house and I thought I'd
come home one day and they'd all be torn
down and break my [ __ ] heart and he
didn't he didn't [ __ ] tear them down
but and all the dudes that I had
on my wall were were are now all my
friends but also everybody everybody I
admired
was not Latino they were either
African-American or they were or they
were whites they weren't they weren't
Latinos because there wasn't there
wasn't somebody until Friday to me until
Freddie friends yeah yeah that's how it
was for me with like music and stuff
like even like uh Comics all of them
were like black until yeah okay locals
came out hey wait but Music Man I mean
you know we we you know the uh you know
Jorge Santana passed away you know as a
model you know oh that's right so were
they brothers or they had bad beef and
they got back together and they played
together so
I went to the center there in San
Francisco where the where the Warriors
play Santana opened it and War and I
emceed
and Jorge Santana was back there and he
had a guitar and was telling me about
guitars that looked like fenders but
they're Knockouts are from Japan and
they're not as much and I was in there
playing with them you know I played not
just [ __ ] around and he's and and he
sent me
a picture of us with a message that said
amen I got a guitar for you man hit me
up but I didn't get my number it was a
Facebook and he passed away and I didn't
see the message till after and I sent it
to Carlos to see what how his brother
was and he was just like man are you
serious bro like thank you so much now
come on damn dude that's good
all right so here it is a week from
Sunday I'm taking a private plane from
Van Nuys or Burbank just to Las Vegas to
go see Santana and come back in the same
day
that's awesome you guys want to go with
me up in the room the other night you
said you you I was just mentioning that
he was upstairs
I'm down I'm gonna take the people from
the new show
and we're all going to go and come back
in the same in the same day
go over there to the show go down say
hello power respect and come back
man all right good job coming in brother
oh No George come on thank you
congratulations thanks for coming thank
you
extension belt for the seat belt
great
we're going Chicano air he's already
told me if they do a life story on me
they're gonna get uh fluffy
detective hey but you know uh uh let's
hey you know what uh come and get covert
tested on my show yeah and come and hang
around and see how it works and let's
put you on the show man but you but come
and get Tech become a [ __ ] testing
yeah you got it yeah bro it's like it's
crazy right I'm there I'm there
to go on the uh yeah yeah we had to show
them but I want you to come down and see
what it's like on the ground all right
yeah and and let's start to let's start
to work on your damn sure man don't know
man thank you I appreciate that right
now that girl could be the dude that
then uh waves across
it oh
Jerry
yeah
I think you got some point you could do
that where where you're like oh man
let's get out here my neighbor's almost
10 15.
trip right now
the [ __ ] dads ran through the [ __ ]
screen door with Jerry [ __ ] chasing
them with us
the sun chasing with a belt all right
thanks for coming in bro thanks for
coming down to the next special to the
show and to all the big things oh man
thank you yeah you deserve man catch a
special uh streaming now on HBO max Mr
tough life yeah anything else to plug
it thank you give me the Mr tough life
story tough life story
that's a great name the name we were
just trying to figure out a name we were
thinking about like I forgive you and
stuff like that and then um but then I I
just remember my dad just like
everything like when I complained
and that would be my nickname or like
it's their tough life so he says that in
the joke and uh that's it that's it
that's how he is he finds one thing you
complain about he'll use it against you
to be your nickname okay you don't love
me all right mister you don't love me
come here yeah
say now that you've got the now I got I
got the uh no I know are you on TV I
always knew
I'll tell you what happened in both ways
I'll tell you one thing about my dad
yeah I'll give him what I'll give him
this dude when I first went out here I
had no money and I was like a place
where I was broke and he said you're
gonna go you're gonna ask for money come
on so nobody asking I gotta go and this
is what I want to do I went I was broke
the first week I [ __ ] came with like
a thousand dollars I burned that [ __ ] in
the [ __ ] week and I told my pastor
asked me I can't and he said like
and I was like no I can't I can't and he
knew I was working these little jobs and
then he was like what do you need what
do you need I know I need a [ __ ] do
stand up and I can't have to pay bills
he's like
Mira I'm gonna give you one year I die
whatever you need and oh man like I get
[ __ ] up thinking about because it's
like I thought I was never gonna get
that from him and I felt like a relief
and I was like damn all right give me
that so that's why when I would go on
stage I said [ __ ] that I'm not playing
here yep my dad is sacrificing my family
sacrifice I'm sacrificing time to see
them they're growing every time I see
them they're getting older like that's
just doing something to me so when I go
on stage it was like I'm perfecting this
I'm not playing right and that's that
was the that was what I needed from him
so I'm always going to be grateful to
him that's right and my sister just gave
me her car she's like then my car broke
down halfway to Phoenix he said here's
my car go back home don't even worry
about it so now they're very like
they're they're happy they're seeing
things are like happening for me because
like they feel bad knowing every year
there's like uh we'll see we'll see now
they're like all right he's doing it so
but you know we'll see what about a
white person could say I think it's
better if you're using my automobile and
I think it'll be like 10.
so I'm grateful for that yeah you know
man I'm doing it for them too you know
so it's not just me that's why I took
him to New York because it wasn't like
this isn't just me this is them they're
with me too they gained the phone calls
when I say I didn't get it I didn't do
this the show got canceled they feel
what I'm feeling so when I got this they
were as happy as I was so I'm like you
got to be there with me so but you know
what man it's okay to be able to not you
know be the most confident anytime well
I was working at a [ __ ] improv in DC
in the mid 90s
the guy would go out there and before he
would introduce me I would say to myself
I would rather be anywhere else in the
world than where I am right now damn and
[ __ ] walking out on stage I'd say I
would rather be
[ __ ] anywhere else damn then right
here [ __ ] it's just like [ __ ]
defeated man yeah like [ __ ] this [ __ ]
man and it it could
they can happen you know I I was just
the opposite I never had a family that
treated me bad or my my dad wouldn't
make fun of me wouldn't do anything else
and all I ever wanted in life yeah was
to make my dad proud that's all that's
all I ever wanted in life was to make
him proud yeah I heard the story that he
did for you so he finally did finally
did
so I'm happy he's about to draw cries at
drawings
it's called Art okay
there's a white dude to his dad
his titties
certain songs that hit me
I just started crying I don't know what
it is
that drawing was good it was good
my kids they looked it just looked like
my dad but you know man like you're
you're like your mom and dad are still
alive yeah you know yours are gone mine
are gone and my grand mother and
grandfather are gone and and you know I
have somehow a picture of my grandmother
ended up in my dressing room or the NBC
and I spent like five minutes looking at
it man like just looking at it and I
could
hear her voice and see her in that time
but she passed away in 2009 but was
really vacant from like 2004 to nine
but to look back when I was a kid and
that was the most important person in my
life like I would see her and look at
her and I would say to myself in the car
I would say man if anything happened to
this lady man I don't know what I would
do
damn you know damn if she passed you and
somebody said oh you know I was 14 and
my mother passed away it's like I would
look at her and I would say to myself if
anything happened to this woman right
here I don't know what I would do damn
[ __ ] and even though she was not the
nicest lady she was nice for her like
when when she said you made me nice
I don't know her [ __ ] life and as
much as you try to tell me I wouldn't
know her life and it was not easy but
you know what
it's not easy it's not just her [ __ ]
it's not easy yeah yeah it's not easy it
was a bunch of [ __ ] she was going
through yeah everybody yeah like that
yeah I wish you would have said that
instead of saying you don't know my life
she probably would have said you know
what don't have my life instead of you
don't know my name like let me in tell
me what the [ __ ] happened when I did
that that and the joke I talked to my
dad and I did that it really happened
but it's not like dramatic like that
better I had a moment where it was like
I was scared like you know what [ __ ] you
did this and that and I told him
everything and he just said and my dad's
like you okay and what about me well the
things that I sacrificed for you
I'm expecting a thank you or nothing but
but you criticize everything I do but
are you okay what do we we gave up
everything for you and for you to at the
end come back and say oh but you never
did this give us a [ __ ] I gave you this
type of life you're supposed to take
this and run with it and us like my
generation is like the oh we we didn't
have this and then [ __ ] that look what
we have though right because of them so
that's changed the relationship between
me and him to be like I understand every
every sacrifice you did for me
especially when I moved out here and how
hard it is to pay bills and I'm like
they did it with three kids and and them
being around is still is better than
them being gone right because you're
like you're you're absolutely you can't
talk to a memory man like yeah
like you know that's that's the name of
my next album
this might be the wrong one of the
longest this one had it all this was two
hours
for 35 million will already be done yeah
money in my pocket tour yeah I can't
I've been how's that cop in Buffalo over
there it's cool it's cool it's nice and
tight intimate but it's like you know
that's the cities I worked on uh [ __ ]
Southgate HP [ __ ] he's you know all
that air weenies
Willy would do shows I know I never work
with LA mismo because I knew that how he
was I'm like I'd rather not I'd rather
not hey I have a short fuse too and I'm
like I don't play it they say well they
would pay you 200 and after he goes hey
bro you know something happened
120 back what the [ __ ] nah Bros 80 man
give me too much yeah yeah and it feel
good when I work out these spots like
Steven Steakhouse and they're like you
know George used to work here feel like
get the [ __ ] I'm seeing what he saw you
know when I work at Visalia with the
Leonard I just did a thing for Leonard
and he tells me I had George it made me
feel good to be like damn doing what
they did you know you know what man uh
it feels good though when you when you
see when you say you can see what they
saw but like you know I went to my
friend Ernie's house and I saw Richard
Pryor live in Long Beach and then I did
my why are you crying in [ __ ] Long
Beach and I said where would you want to
do it I said man I gotta do it in Long
Beach man and he said and the flowers
that are on the why are you crying
special [ __ ] Richard Pryor similar
flowers
well you know what that's funny they say
that because I was just gonna tell you
that but I did a show for Big Boy and we
did it there and when I was on that
stage I said I saw what George Lopez saw
and that thing I I stood there for 30
seconds not saying nothing I was like
and I kept saying oh man oh man let it's
just it was like I saw what you saw you
can know mine says this is where he did
[ __ ] why are you crying though what I
saw for years it was and then I [ __ ]
went out there and I stood on the stage
in the in the rehearsals and he goes I
got a picture of Richard Pryor who gives
a [ __ ] yeah I [ __ ] saw I stood where
he said that he said man that guy's
taking pictures which [ __ ]
taking pictures nothing's flashing he
goes why you want to take a picture of
me he goes hey I got a picture of
Richard Pryor
I mean man I'm telling you guys this is
[ __ ] good this is crazy all right
awesome all right thanks man oh yeah oh
check out my show sorry again please
make some money if you could come up to
my shows I got a show in uh in Glendale
Arizona at the stir crazy look how my
link in my bio and then at Bellflower I
have two shows October 14th uh seven
o'clock and ten o'clock and then what
are the what are the handles of your
social media oh yeah Jesus the comedian
Jesus the comedian and [ __ ] and then uh
and find me on YouTube I have my own
podcast too with American wannabes and
um uh time flies where I tell stories in
my childhood stories I have in every
interview my parents and so yeah so I
have stories there so yeah